ja meine Damen und Herren und der
Einzelplan 08 Finanzen und der hat man
20 Bundesrechnungshof das sind Debatten
da geht es quasi um den Gesamthaushalt
auch der Finanzminister kriegt mehr Geld
das nur bei Plus 843 Millionen aber
jetzt der Material
in der Fraktionsvorsitzender für den
Bereich leider möchte man sagen
deutliche Kritik vor allem deshalb weil
er nicht ehrlich ist sie geben vor dass
sie im kommenden Jahr 2023 die
Schuldenbremse des Grundgesetzes
einhalten tatsächlich haben Sie Herr
Minister Lindner seit Amtsantritt
eigentlich alle denkbaren Methoden
ausgeschöpft um diese Schuldenbremse des
Grundgesetzes zu umgehen
die Einhaltung
die Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse 2023
betonen beschwören sie fast immer wieder
genauso wie die Aussage keine Steuern
erhöhen es ist das Credo der FDP in
dieser Ampel tatsächlich machen sie das
Gegenteil sie machen Schulden wie kein
Finanzminister vor ihnen und die Aussage
kann man ihn nicht ersparen sie sind
Rekord Schulden Macher präziser müsste
man sagen sie sind Rekord Schulden
bevorrater der Haushalt im nächsten Jahr
2023 wird zwar formal ausgeglichen sein
aber nur deshalb weil Sie sich aus dem
Jahr 2021 und in diesem Jahr 2022 so
viel an Schulden auf Vorrat zusammen
gesammelt haben dass sie dann hoffen
können dass sie in den nächsten beiden
Jahren damit unter Einhaltung der
Schuldenbremse durchkommen sie haben 60
Milliarden Kredit Ermächtigung per
Nachtrag aus
21 gebunkert 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögen und 200 Milliarden für
ihren doppelwumms sie nennen das jetzt
Abwehrschirm
140 Milliarden machen sie an neuen
Schulden an einem laufenden Jahr das
sind zusammen 500 Milliarden insgesamt
in einem Jahr das ist die höchste
Neuverschuldung die es in dieser
Republik je gab
[Applaus]
betrug die Gesamtverschuldung des Bundes
am Ende des vergangenen Jahres sie
steigern das jetzt um ein volles Drittel
um 500 Milliarden auf 2000 Milliarden
das ist wirklich Rekord dramatisch und
das möchte ich besonders hervorheben ist
dieser Operation mit dem doppelwurms die
200 Milliarden für den Wirtschaft
stabilisierungsform sie buchen dieses
ganze Geld auf dieses Jahr 2022 ausgeben
wollen sie die Gelder und das sagen sie
auch ausdrücklich aber erst in den
Jahren 2023 2024 für gaspreisbremse und
anderes
jeder der irgendwie klar denken kann
fragt sich wenn die das Geld erst im
nächsten und im übernächsten Jahr
brauchen warum nehmen Sie die Kredite
dann nicht erst im nächsten und im
übernächsten Jahr auf jeder ja über ihre
Feinmechanik können wir dann nachher
noch mal reden Herr Volker buchen nein
sie haben die buchungsmechanik geändert
im Haushaltsrecht und genau das führt
dazu dass sie die Schuldenbremse umgehen
können genau diesen Mechanismus haben
sie geschaffen sie buchen alle diese
Gelder auf das Jahr 2022 und kein
vernünftiger Mensch würde das so tun
jeder nimmt die Kredite dann auch wenn
er sie braucht und bringt sie dann hier
durch den Bundestag so dass wir die
Milliarden im Einzelnen überprüfen
können so sie machen diese ganze
Operation nur um pseudomäßig sagen zu
können dass sie im nächsten Jahr die
Schuldenbremse einhalten und der
Bundesrechnungshof hat das sehr klar und
deutlich benannt er sagt diese
kreditermächtigung für den
Stabilisierungsfonds kollidiert mit dem
Verfassungsgrundsatz der Jährlichkeit
eine
schuldenregelkonforme Kreditaufnahme
dürfen nur jahresbezogen erfolgen
Sondervermögen mit eigenen Kredit
Ermächtigungen Bergen sonst die Gefahr
des Missbrauchs in sich eine nicht
verfassungskonforme Kreditaufnahme
Morgen und genau darum geht es hier
könnte so durch eine bereits auf Vorrat
erfolgte Schuldenaufnahme heute umgangen
werden genau das sagt der
Bundesrechnungshof soll mit der
Kreditaufnahme auf Vorrat durch den
Stabilisierungsfonds Geschehen präziser
und klarer kann man es nicht erläutern
wie sie die Verfassung hier umgehen
ihr grüner Amtskollege in
Baden-Württemberg ja bei Jass hat es
sogar noch ganz einfach auf die Formel
gebracht der Bundesfinanzminister will
die Schuldenbremse auf dem Papier
einhalten und hat dafür einen Sondertopf
angefüllt diesen Trick können die Länder
leider nicht anwenden das kann man auch
nicht klarer und deutlicher sagen Herr
Lindner die Aussage kann ich Ihnen auch
nicht ersparen sie sind der
Schuldenbremsen umgehungsminister und
der ich wiederhole es noch mal Rekord
Schulden bevorrater ihr Haushalt
2023 verdient aber auch deshalb Kritik
weil sie keine Vorsorge für die Zukunft
treffen sie reagieren gar nicht auf die
zeitenwände in ihrem eigenen
eigentlichen Haushalt sondern alles was
irgendwie mit Zeitenwende zu tun hat
wird in sondertöpfe in Sondervermögen
und sonst wie geparkt ein wirkliches
umstrukturieren eine neue Priorisierung
von Aufgaben findet nicht statt am
verteid der Haushalt kann man das
Exemplare sehen der laufende Haushalten
müsste eigentlich anwachsen um das zwei
Prozent Ziel zu erreichen auch um das
umzusetzen was wir mit Ihnen gemeinsam
beschlossen haben im Bundeswehr
finanzierungsgesetz dass wir nämlich
auch Vorsorge treffen dafür wenn das
Sondervermögen ausgelaufen ist all das
tun sie nicht sie frieren den Haushalt
perspektivisch bei 50 Milliarden ein und
wir werden dann im Zweifel in einem
Riesensprung in mehreren Jahren den
Haushalt wieder auffüllen müssen um dann
das zwei Prozent Ziel und die
nato-fähigkeitsziele sicherzustellen
Thema Alterssicherung die SPD und
insbesondere der Bundeskanzler hat damit
ja Werbung gemacht im Wahlkampf und zwar
ganz heftig und hat sich plakatiert als
Kanzler für sichere Renten bisher
geleistet haben Sie in diesem Thema als
das Sicherung nichts die FDP kommt jetzt
mit einem eigentlich guten Vorschlag
nämlich dem Punkt aktienrente wenn man
sich aber ansieht was davon jetzt übrig
geblieben ist von diesem Ansatz dann
wird einem ganz traurig um die Nase der
Kapitalstock soll nicht den Versicherten
sondern der Rentenversicherung zur
Verfügung stehen die 10 Milliarden sind
ein marginaler Betrag und sie werden
jetzt auch nicht aus Kapital dargestellt
sondern auch Schulden das heißt die
Zinsen dafür werden die Rendite
weitgehend auffressen
Bürokratieabbau haben sie uns
versprochen und betonen sie auch immer
wieder als fortschrittskoalition sie
haben sogar eine stelleneinsparung eine
pauschale im Haushalt beschlossen die
erweckt allerdings nur den Eindruck von
Einsparung betont auch hier der
Rechnungshof zu Recht denn sie streichen
nur stellen die ohnehin gar nicht
besetzt sind
in Wirklichkeit satteln sie beim
Personal reichlich drauf das können sie
auf ihrer Regierungsbank hier
besichtigen Sie haben die Rekordzahl an
parlamentarischen Staatssekretären mit
37 sie haben 42
regierungsbeauftragte wir müssen ja
eigentlich demnächst anbauen damit ihre
Regierung überhaupt noch Platz findet
und sie haben eine Rekordzahl an
Spitzenbeamten eingestellt das hat mit
Verantwortlichkeit und auch mit
Bürokratieabbau gar nichts zu tun
sie beschreiben sich immer wieder
als
fortschrittskoalition die nachhaltig
agieren würde
tatsächlich und das kann man leider an
diesem Haushalt
besichtigen belasten sie die jüngere
Generation mit immer mehr Schulden und
damit auch mit immer mehr Zinsen das
wird die Handlungsspielräume gerade der
jüngeren in Zukunft dramatisch
eingrenzen auch für ein wichtiges Thema
wie etwa Klimapolitik ihr Haushalt ist
deshalb eines ganz sicher nicht er ist
nicht ehrlich und er ist auch nicht
nachhaltig herzlichen Dank
Matthias Mittelberg der
stellvertretenden Fraktionsvorsitzende
der cdu/csu ist hier mit dem Haushalt
scharf ins Gericht gegangen vor allen
Dingen den Bundesfinanzminister hat er
an massiv angegriffen Christoph Meyer
jetzt der stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende für diesen Bereich
der FDP wir beschließen den Haushalt
2023 heute vor einer schwierigen
Gesamtlage aber wir schlagen mit diesem
Haushalt den Weg zurück zu einer
stabilitätsorientierten Haushaltspolitik
ein die Wirtschaftslage ist fragil die
Energiekrise ist nicht gelöst und wir
werden eine Rezession rutschen und auf
diese Herausforderungen reagieren wir
angemessen Bundeshaushalt 203 20 und der
wirtschaftliche Abwehrschirm wirken in
Kommunion für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
und die Unternehmen in unserem Land
blicken wir auf die Zahlen
wir mussten die Ausgaben noch einmal
deutlich erhöhen auch 476 Milliarden
Euro
trotz vielfältiger Belastung bleiben wir
aber mit 20 Milliarden Euro unter den
Ansätzen 2022 und das gelingt die
Investition noch einmal um 20 Milliarden
auf jetzt 71 Milliarden Euro zu steigern
wir holen die Versäumnisse der
Vorgängerregierung Stück für Stück auf
das dauert eine Weile aber wir haben uns
auf den Weg gemacht meine Damen und
Herren
und dann behalten wir Wort
wir entlasten indem wir den
vollständigen Ausgleich der kalten
Progression und die größte
Kindergelderhöhung in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland auf den Weg
bringen
insgesamt haben wir im Haushalt 2023
eine Entlastungsvolumen von fast 50
Milliarden Euro
und uns gelingt es den Einstieg in die
aktienrente zu ermöglichen um unser
Rentensystem abzusichern und dies alles
warten dies ab und dies alles tun wir
unter Einhaltung der Schulden bringen
Bremse Herr Mittelberg das war hart
umstritten in der Koalition aber diese
Koalition bekennt sich mit der
Einhaltung zu soliden Finanzpolitik und
das als solches ist schon ein Erfolg für
sich wir zeigen dass die Schuldenbremse
auch in schwierigen Zeiten funktioniert
das genug Spielraum vorhanden ist
die Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse bleibt
damit zentraler Bestandteil für ein
handlungsfähigen Staat und Herr
Mittelberg ich muss mich ehrlich über
ihre Reden wundern Sie persönlich
haben bei der Errichtung von allen
Sondervermögen seitdem sie im Parlament
sind zugestimmt wie biegsam muss man
eigentlich sein dass man das
anschließend kritisiert das zeigt welche
Oppositionspolitik sie hier wirklich
betreiben
und die Union hat im Nachtragshaushalt
2022 das Kunststück fertig gebracht
beides zu tun die Schuldenbremse nicht
einzuhalten 60 Milliarden Euro aus dem
kernetat herauszunehmen und auf der
anderen Seite 600 Milliarden Euro über
ein Sondervermögen ins Schaufenster zu
stellen sie sind nicht nur kein Deutsch
besser wenn Sie das hier kritisieren
sondern sie haben es schlimmer gemacht
wir ordnen die Finanzen das was sie in
den letzten Jahren nicht auf den Weg
gebracht haben und Sie haben die Stellen
angesprochen
auch daher Mittelberg die groko hat
22.000 Stellen in der letzten Legislatur
aufwachsen lassen 22.000 stellen sie
hatten nicht die Kraft einen
minderungsfaktor einzubauen wie die
Ampel jetzt 3.100 Stellen bauen wir im
nächsten Jahr ab und wir werden
sicherlich in den nächsten Jahren diesen
abbaufahrt so weiter fortsetzen und wenn
Sie hier
über die Gas- und strompreisbremsen
abwehrstürmen reden Herr Mittelberg sie
haben den abgelehnt sie haben aber in
Haushaltsberatung keinen anderen
Finanzierungsvorschlag gemacht um den
Menschen um den Unternehmen zu helfen
das wissen Sie vielleicht nicht das
liegt vielleicht auch daran dass sie als
zuständiger Stellvertreter kein einziges
Mal bei den Haushaltsberatung im
Haushaltsausschuss des Deutschen
Bundestages anwesend war
zur Wahrheit gehört aber auch dazu
dass wir die Zinskosten in den Etat
nochmal um 10 Milliarden Euro anpassen
mussten wir werden jetzt mit einem
Betrag von 40 Milliarden Euro im Jahr
2023 planen 36 Milliarden Euro mehr als
vor zwei Jahren zum Vergleich das sind
die etas für Bildung und Forschung und
Familie und Jugend zusammen diese Summe
steht nicht mehr für zukunftsausgaben
zur Verfügung und an den Zinsumfeld wird
sich absehbar nichts ändern deswegen
müssen wir deutlich sagen die Spielräume
für weitere Ausgabenprogramme sind in
diesem Haushalt sind auf der Bundesebene
nicht mehr gegeben und auch dann müssen
wir sagen dass der Haushalt 2023 in der
Art wie wir Krisenbekämpfung und
Vorsorge betreiben natürlich noch sehr
expansiv ist
wir haben den Pfad des undisziplinierten
mehr ausgebens wie zu Zeiten der großen
Koalition wo immer noch einer
draufgelegt wurde verlassen diesen Weg
müssen wir aber in den nächsten Jahren
konsequent weitergehen denn
nach dem Haushalt ist vor dem Haushalt
das Aufstellungsverfahren für den
Haushalt 2024 beginnt im Frühjahr wir
wollen Wachstumsimpulse setzen um den
Wohlstand in unserer Gesellschaft zu
sichern und gleichzeitig werden wir die
Staatsausgaben konsolidieren diese
beiden Prioritäten müssen in den
nächsten Jahren zusammen gehen
meine Damen und Herren
ich möchte Ihnen allen für die nicht
immer einfachen aber doch sehr
konstruktiven Beratung in den letzten
Monaten danken
ich glaube wir waren alle mit dem Ziel
unterwegs dass wir die Ausgaben kritisch
prüfen und zu einem guten Ergebnis
kommen dieses gute Ergebnis liegt Ihnen
jetzt vor und ich freue mich auf die
Beratung in der laufenden Woche ich
danke Ihnen
Christoph Meyer für die FDP und die
Ampel hat er hier noch einmal den
Haushaltsentwurf verteidigt auf die
Entlastung von 50 Milliarden Euro hin
und die schwierige Situation der
Rezession in die die deutsche Wirtschaft
Stolper Peter Böhringer jetzt äh der
haushaltspolitische sprechen der AFD des
Bundes wir haben es gehört liegt 2023
bei fast 100 90 Milliarden Euro das ist
ein Vielfaches der offiziell von der
Regierung behaupteten Zahl von 45
Milliarden die in den sogenannten
Sondervermögen aufgenommen Schulden
werden formell einfach nicht mitgezählt
ein Trick übrigens Herr Mittelberg ja
den sie mit der Union mit der groko 2021
eingeführt haben das ist die Wahrheit
fast 150 Milliarden Euro Neuverschuldung
werden so 2023 verschleiert die
jahresgenau einzuhaltende Schuldenregel
des Grundgesetzes wird umgangen wir
fordern das Haus auf hier gegen noch ein
kontrollklage einzureichen unser Antrag
dazu liegt vor
faktisch faktisch agiert der
Finanzminister im Haus ätherischen
Notstand zurückzuführen vor allem auf
die dümmste Energiepolitik der Welt
Energie ist das Lebensblut jeder
modernen Wirtschaft Ideologen und
ignoranten alle Regierungsparteien ist
es in Jahrzehnten fehlgeleitete
Energiepolitik gelungen Deutschland an
den Rand der d-industrialisierung zu
führen und das sage ich nicht so
leichtfertig das wird den Wohlstand
breiter Bevölkerungsgruppen drastisch
reduzieren die volkswirtschaftlichen
Kosten dieser ideologischen
Energiepolitik sind einfach zu groß man
kann sie nicht aus Steuermitteln
kompensieren trotzdem wird genau das mit
den energiepreisdeckeln und versucht die
rot gelb grün schwarzen
Realitätsverweigerer versuchen Krisen
symptomatisch statt ursächlich zu lösen
[Applaus]
wir alle bekommen hier jeden Tag
hilferufende Briefe von existenziell
bedrohten Menschen von Unternehmen und
Verbänden alle brauchen mehr Energie
Strom und Gas sonst droht der
massenhafte Abzug von
Produktionskapazitäten und
Arbeitsplätzen doch die amperegierung
beschließt noch nicht einmal die
Verlängerung der Kernkraftnutzung und
was macht die FDP dabei offiziell war
sie monatelang für die Verlängerung der
Kernkraft doch statt wenigstens diese
Minimalforderung irgendwie durchzusetzen
macht der Finanzminister lupenreine
basta Politik gegen die offiziellen
fdp-versprechungen gegen niedrigere
Strompreise gegen die Menschen man
erklärt zur Verlängerung der Laufzeiten
über lächerliche 100 Tage hinaus
schlicht jetzt ist Ende all das zeigt
wieder einmal deutlich auf ein fdp-wort
ist einfach kein Verlass
[Applaus]
und dann spricht der Finanzminister auch
noch diesen absurden Satz aus ich
übernehme die Verantwortung für jeden
Euro Schulden ja toll davon kann sich
Deutschland etwas kaufen zumal die
Schäden ihrer Politik Herr Lindner noch
nachwirken werden wenn sie schon lange
nicht mehr im Amt sind
zur aktienrente wir haben sie eben ganz
stolz gehört von der FDP ein weiteres
neues fdp-projekt man muss es zur klar
sagen eine tolle Idee wäre das gewesen
vor 40 Jahren aber selbst dann nicht bei
der gesetzlichen Rentenversicherung denn
diese hat einfach keinen Kapitalstock
den irgendwie in Aktien investieren
könnte also nimmt die Regierung nun
einfach mal 10 Milliarden Schulden auf
um sie dann irgendwie in den Aktienmarkt
zu stecken und man führt eine riskante
Wette auf aus auf Renditen über die
Kredit Zinsen hinaus die aktienrente
deckt sogar unter der Annahme guter
Aktien und Börsenentwicklung noch nicht
einmal ein zweitausendste der
rentenzahlungsverpflichtung der nächsten
Jahre bei der GHV das ganze ist ein
schlechter Witz reines Symbolpolitik
zu den Zinskosten eben schon gehört es
sind 42 Milliarden Euro und auch hier
gilt viele alte Fehlentscheidungen vor
denen die AFD seit Jahren warnt wirken
nun fatale im Haushalt jahrelang hatten
wir einen 0 und negativzinsniveau
jahrelang haben wir als AFD dem
Finanzminister Scholz immer wieder
vorgebetet nutzen Sie dieses niedrige
historische Niveau aus seit 2017 hätte
man nullzinsen teilweise sogar
Negativzinsen für deutsche neue Schulden
auf 30 Jahre festschreiben können getan
hat es der heutige Kanzler nie der
angerichtete Schaden nur durch dieses
riesige Versäumnis beträgt künftig
mindestens 10 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr
das ist etwa einmal der deutsche
cum-ex-schaden für die nächsten 30 Jahre
jedes Jahr falls es für eine Scholz
geführte Regierung dann leichter
einzuordnen ist
Realität werden soll 2023 auch ein
hochgefährliches und
gesellschaftsveränderndes Projekt ein
sogenanntes Bürgergeld das dank der
Großzügigkeit der Ampel bedingungslos an
die Bedürftigen aus aller Welt gezahlt
wird
2023 werden dafür viele Milliarden Euro
in den Haushalt eingestellt mal sehen ob
es reichen wird hinzu kommt noch
Kindergeld für nicht EU-Ausländer man
führt hier unglaublich starke
prüfaktoren für noch mehr Zuwanderung
ins deutsche Sozialsystem ein und schon
heute ist klar dass mehr als 40 Prozent
dieser bürgergeldempfänger Ausländer
sein werden Tendenz sehr schnell
steigend
für alle nicht nur für Ausländer nimmt
man zugleich auch noch allen Menschen
die niedrigen Lohngruppen den Anreiz
überhaupt zu arbeiten bei einem nur noch
geringen nettolohnabstand zwischen zum
Beispiel 2000 Euro verdienen und den
neuern bürgergeld-empfängern werden sich
immer mehr Menschen gegen jede Arbeit
entscheiden was ja übrigens heute schon
ein Grund für den Arbeitskräftemangel in
ganz vielen anstrengenden Berufen ist
und da den neuen bürgergeldempfängern ja
auch noch das Wohngeld und auch die
Heizkosten bedingungs- und grenzenlos
gezahlt werden dann könnte der Status
als bürgergeldner demnächst hoch
attraktiv werden und es wird sich in
alle Welt herumsprechen das seine
horende Heizung selbst zahlen der noch
arbeitende Volk wird dagegen in der
Wohnung frieren dürfen
der Regierung ist jedes verantwortungs-
und Gerechtigkeitsgefühl für
leistungsbereite Menschen abhanden
gekommen diese Zahlen nämlich wie immer
für solche sozialistische Ideologie
herzlichen
[Applaus]
Redner für die SPD-Fraktion Achim post
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich weiß
das nicht ganz genau über welchen
Bundeshaushalt welchen Landes mein
Vorredner gerade geredet hat ich rede
über den Bundeshaushalt der stärksten
Volkswirtschaft in Europa über den
Bundeshaushalt einer lebendigen
weltoffenen und toleranten Demokratie
und ich rede über den Bundeshaushalt
eines stabilen Landes in der Mitte
Europas mit einer stabilen
handlungsfähigen Regierungen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und
Mittelberg ich darf Sie daran erinnern
dass 81 Tage nach Amtsantritt dieser
Bundesregierung Putin ein aggressiven
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine vom
zaumgebrochen hat ich darf Sie daran
erinnern dass wir nicht nur akute Krisen
bekämpfen müssen sondern auch
langfristige strukturelle wie eine sich
immer weiter zuspitzende Klimakrise wir
haben vor uns die Transformation unserer
Volkswirtschaft die industrielle
Transformation unserer Volkswirtschaft
zusammengenommen wir leben in einer
wirklich schwierigen
sicherheitspolitischen
Bedrohungslage die selten zuvor seit
1949 und deshalb ist es angemessen
deshalb ist es angemessen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen mal darüber zu
reden worum geht es eigentlich in diesem
Bundeshaushalt was ist das Wichtigste
was sind die drei wichtigsten Punkte ich
sag mal ein paar das wichtigste ist die
Handlungsfähigkeit des Staates in diesen
Krisen und Kriegszeiten zu zeigen und
diese Bundesregierung und dieses
Parlament zeigt diese Handlungsfähigkeit
diese staatliche Handlungsfähigkeit
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und nun mag man manches zu klein zu spät
[Musik]
erachten finden wenn ich in Brüssel in
anderen europäischen Hauptstadt
unterwegs bin dann höre ich ganz andere
Töne dann ist das vielen unserer Länder
zu früh zu groß zu mächtig und zu
wuchtig vielleicht liegt die Wahrheit
woanders aus meiner Sicht zeigt diese
Bundesregierung und zeigen diese
Koalitionsfraktionen mit den 200
Milliarden für die gaspreisbremse und
die strompreisbremse die beide kommen
und die zeitig kommen werden die
Handlungsfähigkeit diese Staates und
dieser Bundesregierung liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
die drei entlastungspakete die drei
entlastungspakete über 95 Milliarden
Euro sind alle ausbilanziert ist alles
in diesem Bundeshaushalt das heißt es
wurde viel geredet wir haben gehandelt
und wir werden weiter Handeln liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und
über das Sondervermögen Bundeswehr jetzt
noch mal zu reden das kann man alles
machen ich wir die Mehrheit dieses
Hauses war und ist der Ansicht dass
diese Sondervermögen für die Bundeswehr
notwendig ist um die Bundeswehr zu
ertüchtigen weiter zur tüchtigen und
genau das ist die richtige Politik liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
zweiter Punkt zweiter Punkt dieser
Bundeshaushalt zeigt worauf es auch
ankommt auf Zusammenhalt in der
Zeitenwende also wenn ich ein bisschen
mal nach links gucke der größte
einzeletat ist a und S ist Arbeit und
Soziales ungefähr ein Drittel des
gesamten Bundeshaushalts das heißt diese
Bundesregierung setzt fort und verstärkt
eine soziale Politik für die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger in diesem Lande liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und wenn ich mal ein Beispiel nehmen
kann
ein Kindergeld ab dem ersten Kind ab dem
ersten 23 von 250 Euro das ist kein
Pappenstiel das ist die größte
Kindergelderhöhung in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und worum es auch geht dass der dritte
Punkt es geht um Verantwortung für die
Zukunft die anderen Krisen sind doch
nicht weg weil die Russen und bei
Russland und Putin in der Ukraine
eingefallen ist die Klimakrise spitzt
sich immer weiter zu und deshalb ist es
richtig dass wir rekordinvestitionen der
Kollege Meyer hat darauf hingewiesen in
diesem Bundeshaushalt gegen den
Klimawandel für soziale für die soziale
Zukunft unseres Landes und für die
Transformation unserer Industrie
organisieren und das macht nur diese
Bundesregierung liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und eins möchte ich sagen und ganz
wichtiger Punkt das der Kollege Mayer
hat es angesprochen was die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter im
Finanzministerium im Haushaltsausschuss
in den Fraktionen in den letzten Tagen
und Wochen geleistet hat das ist
allergeneur ich ziehe meinen Mut dafür
wenn ich einen hätte
und namentlich
namentlich möchte ich erwähnen Sven
Christian Kindler otro Fricke und Dennis
Rohde der lag an corode erkrankt ist
heute nicht teilnehmen kann schöne Grüße
nach Oldenburg nächstes mal bist du
wieder dabei Dennis
und eins gerade wurde die
Bereinigungssitzung angesprochen die
Bereinigungssitzung wurde
souverän fair ruhig geleitet von
hellgrauen im Vorsitzenden des
Haushaltsausschusses dafür herzlichen
Dank und meinen Respekt
und wenn wir in die Zukunft gucken und
das was wir vor uns haben in dieser
Haushaltsdebatte in den nächsten Wochen
und Monaten
dann muss ich mal eins sagen ich bin
fest davon überzeugt das ist ein
Haushalt der pragmatischen Vernunft das
ist ein Haus als es ein Haushalt der
Zuversicht und diese Zuversicht die
sollten wir uns bewahren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die haben wir
dringend nötig es ist besser
zuversichtlich und selbstbewusst in die
Zukunft zu gehen als verzagt und
verkümmert und mit runtergezogenen
Schultern deshalb liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen mein herzlicher Dank an die
Bundesregierung und ganz besonders an
dem Bundesfinanzminister der einen
klugen einen sehr klugen
haushalts-entwurf vorgelegt hat der
wurde noch ein bisschen verbessert in
den Beratung ich glaube da haben sie
nichts gegen von daher zusammengefasst
ein guter Haushaltsentwurf eine kluge
Politik der Bundesregierung verlangt
da lächelt der Bundesfinanzminister mild
ein Lob von Achim Post passiert ja auch
nicht jeden Tag die Ampel vermittelt
hier das Signal wir stehen zusammen
Gesine lötchen jetzt die
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitzende
der Linksfraktion und
haushaltspolitische Sprecherin
sind immer ein Geschenk
K für in Kris
enblock sie müssen diese dreiste
Umverteilung endlich stoppen alles
andere ist ein Skandal meine Damen und
Herren
diese Bundesregierung darf eben nicht
Vermögensverwalter der gastspekulanten
Stromhändler Waffenhersteller und
immobilienkonzerne sein doch sie weigern
sich beharrlich die krisengewinne zu
besteuern selbst die mickrige
zufallsgewinnsteuer steht in den Sternen
und die stromlobbyisten sorgen dafür
dass diese Steuer auf ein Minimum
eingedampft wird sie Herr Bundeskanzler
haben gesagt wir müssen uns alle
unterhaken aber sie dürfen nicht nur die
Krisengewinner unterhalten das ist nicht
sozial gerecht meine Damen und Herren
es ist doch nicht so dass das höhere
Wohngeld bei den Mieterinnen und Mietern
bleibt sondern das Geld geht zum großen
Teil an die immobilienkonzerne deshalb
fordern wir endlich einen bundesweiten
mietendeckel und endlich den Bau der
versprochenen 100.000 Sozialwohnungen ja
meine Damen und Herren
und es ist doch nicht so
dass die Gas- und strompreisbremse die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zuverlässig
verkälte schützt die Bremse macht auch
die Strom und Gasanbieter noch reicher
und deshalb fordern wir endlich eine
übergewinnsteuer meine Damen und Herren
und es ist noch nicht so dass 50 Euro
Hartz IV armen Menschen einen vollen
Kühlschrank bescheren und gleichzeitig
werden all die und Lidl noch reicher wir
als LINKE fordern einen preisdeckel für
Grundnahrungsmittel und null Prozent
Mehrwertsteuer auf diese Produkte das
wäre der richtige Weg
und meine Damen und Herren es ist doch
nicht so dass die zusätzlichen 100
Milliarden Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr und das größte Bundeswehr
Budget von aller Zeiten von 64
Milliarden Euro die Bundeswehr sinnvoll
ausstattet und vor allem unser Leben
sich vermacht sondern sie treiben die
Aktienkurse der Rüstungsindustrie in den
Himmel deshalb fordern wir deutlich mehr
Sicherheit durch Diplomatie und
Verhandlung statt durch Aufrüstung das
wäre der richtige Weg meine Damen und
Herren und an dieser Stelle muss ich
auch sagen wir alle in diesem Saal
verurteilen den völkerrechtswidrigen
Krieg Russlands gegen die Ukraine
Regierung auch dass sie deutlich den
völkerrechtswidrigen Krieg Erdogans
gegen die Kurden verurteilt und nicht
nur von einer schwierigen Situation
spricht dieser Krieg muss beendet werden
meine Damen und Herren
sie haben einen 10 Milliarden Euro
Aktien rentenpaket aus dem Boden
gestampft aber bei der
Kindergrundsicherung arbeiten sie mit
angezogene Handbremse das ist die
falsche Priorität des Freitag haben wir
noch die Chance etwas zu ändern
herzlichen Dank
so und jetzt dürfen für die Ampel
Fraktionen noch die haushaltspolitischen
Sprecher ran nämlich Sven Christian
Kindler für die Bündnisgrünen wie gesagt
haushaltspolitischer Sprecher seiner
Fraktion sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
meine Damen und Herren und liegen fast
drei Monate Haushaltsberatung im
Ausschuss und im Plenum hinter uns und
ich möchte mehrere Punkte ansprechen die
mir aufgefallen sind erster Punkt wir
zeigen als koalitionsfraktion mit diesem
Bundeshaus seit 23 werde Haus des
Gesetzgeber ist auch gegenüber der
eigenen Regierung die wir tragen der
moskoalition ein entscheidenden Stellen
maßgabebeschlüsse verabschiedet da wo es
notwendig war auch sperren eingeführt
und haben mit 526 Änderungsanträgen am
Bundeshaushalt 23 diesen Entwurf einen
entscheidenden Stellen verbessert und
auch korrigiert
und manche in der Opposition oder Medien
deuten das dann falsch aber das ist die
ureigene Rolle des Parlaments gegenüber
der Exekutive in der geweihten Teilung
unserer Demokratie und diese Aufgabe
sind wir als koalitionsfraktion
nachgekommen und deswegen trägt dieser
Haushalt auch die klare Handschrift des
Parlaments
zweiter Punkt wir stehen als Koalition
zu unserem Wort wir haben als Koalition
in dieser Krise immer gesagt wir lassen
die Menschen mit ihren Sorgen mit ihren
Ängsten in diesen schweren Krisenzeiten
nicht alleine sondern wir unterstützen
Sie wir unterstützen die vielen
Unternehmen die vielen Vereine wir
unterstützen die Einrichtungen jetzt
Angesicht forcieren Energiekrise
angesichts des brutalen angustries
Putins und wir halten unser Wort und das
jetzt konkret in diesem Haushalt um
Achim Poss hat es angesprochen wir haben
drei entlastungspakete in Höhe von 95
Milliarden Euro die wir umsetzen mit
diesem Bundeshaushalt und ein
wirtschaftstabilisierungsfonds an Höhe
von 200 Milliarden Euro zusammen macht
das 300 Milliarden Euro damit
finanzieren wir die gaspreisbremse damit
finden Sie mir die strompreisbremse den
härtefallfonds das Bürgergeld die
wohngeldreform Hilfen für Renten und
Rentner Studierende Azubis das höhere
Kindergeld das 49 Euro Ticket und vieles
vieles mehr wir lassen die Menschen der
schweren Krise nicht alleine wir sollen
Stabilität und Sicherheit in diesem
Krisenzeiten
und ja ja das ist ein großes
entlassungspaket aber das Paket ist eben
auch so groß weil die Krisen leider auch
so groß ist ich will daran erinnern
welcher schweren Lage wir uns befinden
wir haben ein brutalen angustrie mitten
in Europa wir haben eine fossile schwere
Energiekrise und die Klimakatastrophe
eskaliert immer mehr und der Situation
wäre es natürlich auch eine Möglichkeit
dann angesichts Überforderung im
Stillstand zu verharren oder die
Probleme weg zu ignorieren aber das
haben wir nicht gemacht wir gehen diese
Krisen eben entschlossen an und ich will
daran erinnern wo wir gestartet sind als
diese Regierung angefangen hat waren die
Gasspeicher von Peter Altmaier leer
jetzt sind sie über 100%, eine
gefährliche gastmangelage wird diesen
Winter höchstwahrscheinlich vermieten
werden wir haben das größte
Gesetzespaket für erneuerbaren Energien
vor dem Sommer seit 20 Jahren durch den
Deutschen Bundestag gebracht und die
Wirtschaftsdaten sich jetzt auch und es
gibt wieder mehr Zuversicht in diesem
Land alles das haben wir gemacht das
Koalition das zeigt wir gehen das
entschlossen an diese Krisen
und wir zeigen mit diesem Haushalt auch
dass wir Angesicht des russischen
Imperialismus die Ukraine weiter
unterstützen humanitär wir unterstützen
die diplomatisch wir unterstützen Sie
bei der Aufnahme der geflüchteten in
Deutschland wir unterstützen Sie mit
Wirtschaftshilfen und wir unterstützen
Sie auch militärisch und wir werden das
weiter tun
denn wir gucken anders als manche
Nationalisten hier im Haus eben nicht
nur auf das nationale sondern wir wissen
dass wir als in einer gemeinsamen
vernetzten Welt leben und als große
Industrienationen als reich Industrie
Nation auch eine globale Solidarität und
Verantwortung haben denn der Angriff den
Putins löst ja nicht nur unschrecklich
fassbares Leid aus in der Ukraine
sondern er verschärft auf Weltmeister
weltweit die massiv die Krisen und
deswegen haben wir noch mal für 20 22
eine Milliarde Euro für den Kampf gegen
Hunger in der vereinigungssitzung
freigegeben deswegen werden wir was
Auswärtige Amt und das
Entwicklungsministerium jetzt insgesamt
zwei Milliarden Euro für den Haushalt 23
zur Verfügung stellen für humanitäre
Hilfe für Krisenprävention für das
Menschenrecht auf Nahrung wir sagen das
Parlament sehr klar dass wir ein
Schwerpunkt hier auf internationale
Gerechtigkeit leben
und dritter Punkt normalerweise gelten
die Haushaltsberatung ja auch als Stunde
der Opposition wo man die Regierung mit
konkreten Alternativen vor sich
hertreibt oder aber auch und auch in
Krisenzeiten natürlich auch
staatstragend Verantwortung übernimmt in
der Gemeinschaft der DemokratInnen und
Demokraten ich hätte mir das bei der
Union diesen Haushaltsverfahren auch
gewünscht ich hoffe dass wir am nächsten
Haushalt anders läuft denn wir haben es
leider nicht gesehen und wir meine
Kritik konkret machen am 21 Oktober
haben wir hier im Deutschen Bundestag
die 200 Milliarden Euro Finanzierung für
den wirtschaftsstabilisierungsform
beschlossen und die Union hat dagegen
gestimmt
Finanzminister
als
und die Union hat damals am 21 Oktober
dagegen gestimmt weil sie gesagt haben
sie wollen keine Finanzierungen über der
Sondervermögen und ich hatte ihn
erwartet dass sie im Haus das Verfahren
dann andere Alternative
Finanzierungsvorschläge vorlegen zum
Beispiel gerechte Steuererhöhungen
Einsparung oder eben auch eine
Finanzierung über die notfallregel der
Schuldenbremse 23 das haben Teil
Mittelberg ja auch eine Debatte am 21
Oktober angedeutet aber es kam nichts es
kam kein Antrag eine Bereinigungssitzung
gar nichts Herr Mittelberg vielleicht
wissen sie es ja nicht sie waren ja nie
im Haushaltsausschuss im gesamten
Verfahren aber sie haben keine andere
ernährungsverträge vorgelegt für die
Finanzierung
und ich will die Union auch ernst jemals
Opposition und wenn ich die Union ernst
nehmen will dann muss ich ja verstehen
sie haben die Finanzierung für die
Strom- und gaspreisbremse abgelehnt sie
haben keine Alternative
Finanzierungsvorschläge im
Haushaltsverfahren vorgelegt und ich
kann Ihnen sagen Hausarzt klaren
Haushalts Wahrheit gilt auch für die
Opposition
und wenn sie keine konkrete Finanzierung
vorlegen heißt es im Ende auch sie leben
diese Hilfen ab sie wollen keine
energiehilfen für die Menschen und für
Unternehmen sie lassen den Wecker am
Regen stehen sie lassen die Menschen in
der Kälte alleine mit ihren mit ihrer
Politik aber das werden wir konkret
nicht zulassen
[Applaus]
ja ich würde sagen wir Treffer hat
gesessen sie haben eben konkret nichts
vorgelegt im Ausschuss was die
Finanzierung gerechtfertigt hätte immer
nur populistisch kritisieren was wir
anders machen sollen das Regierung aber
keine konkreten
Änderungsanträge Vorschlägen das geht so
nicht also Union sie müssen schon mal
sich entscheiden welche Obsession sie
wollen dann konstruktiv staatstragen und
nur populistisch
vierter Punkt wir stabilisieren nicht
nur eine Krisen sondern denken jetzt
auch an das morgen die Klimakatastrophe
eskaliert immer mehr deswegen haben wir
auch noch mal sehr konkret
Energieeffizienz internationalen
nationalen Klimaschutz in dem Haus ist
Entwurf gestärkt wir haben 1,5
Milliarden Euro für die Schiene
zusätzliche bereitgestellt und wir haben
700 Millionen Euro für kommunale
Investition bereitet wir haben
rekordination in diesem Haushalt das
zeigt wir gehen die Krisen entschlossen
an wir bauen jetzt soziale ökologisch
für die Zukunft um deswegen kann ich nur
die Empfehlung im Bundeshaushalt
zuzustimmen danke
Sven Christian Kindler der Haushälter
der Bündnis Grünen hat festgestellt
dieser Etat eine klare Handschrift des
Parlaments anders wird das Christian
Hase sehen der haushaltspolitische
Sprecher der CDU Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen zunächst einmal
auch Genesungswünsche in Richtung Dennis
Rode hätte ihn gerne heute hier gehabt
vielleicht schafft das ja bis Donnerstag
mal Corona geht das ja manchmal schnell
ja über 45 Milliarden neue Schulden für
den Bund dass das traurige Ergebnis der
Haushaltsberatung 45 Milliarden die
unsere Kinder irgendwann mit Zins und
Zinsen sind zurückzahlen müssen 45
Milliarden Euro die unsere
Handlungsfähigkeit in der Zukunft
einschränken dabei waren es im
Regierungsentwurf nur 17 Milliarden Euro
die Ampel hält das haben wir ja heute
schon gehört zwar die Schuldenbremse ein
aber sie nutzt den Verschuldung
Spielraum der Konjunktur Komponente
vollkommen nutzt die vollkommen aus aber
sollte man nicht tun müssen wir haben
Krisen seit der Kollege Kindler gerade
noch mal darauf hingewiesen da hätte man
etwas Geld zurückhalten können aber so
etwas kommt in der ampelogik leider
nicht vor da wird keine Vorsorge
behalten zum Beispiel für die
Sozialversicherung da schiebt man jetzt
an die Beitragszahler an also wenn Sie
eine Erhöhung ihrer Beitragszahlung in
der Krankenversicherung bekommen das
hätten wir anders regeln können da hat
die Ampel andere Prioritäten gesetzt
also geht es um schuldenfinanzierte
Befriedung von ampelinteressen da
kriecht die Frau Roth 200 €
Begrüßungsgeld in der Erwachsenenwelt er
heil bekommt seinen Bürgergeld Frau
bärburg 8 Millionen Euro für selbst
ernannte Seenotretter Herr Wissing
bekommt ein billig Ticket für die
urbanen Räume und unser
Bundesfinanzminister darf weitere
Darlehen aufnehmen diesmal für eine
aktienrente nur eine Dame bekommt leider
nichts das ist Frau Lamprecht das ist
aber Dings dann auch erstmal richtig so
weil sie hat besser nicht gezeigt dass
sie in der Lage ist sie zur Verfügung
gestellten Mittel auch tatsächlich
auszugeben das hätten wir uns anders
gewünscht wir haben gezeigt da hätte man
ordentlich drauflegen müssen denn da
muss endlich Dampf in die Sache rein
die Koalition handelt also ganz nach dem
Motto die neuen Schulden brauchen wir ja
nicht mehr zurückzahlen dann sind wir
schon lange nicht mehr im Amt im
ampelsprecht heißt das dann alle drei
Koalitionspartner finden sich in diesem
Haushalt wieder dabei verkennt die Ampel
an welchem Kipppunkt unsere Wirtschaft
steht welche Investitionen in Sicherheit
erforderlich werden und dass die
Tragfähigkeit der Staatsfinanzen doch in
Gefahr sind dabei müsste sie das doch
eigentlich wissen die
Entschließungsanträge der FDP zum ersten
und zweiten Nachtrag 2020 da kann ich
reingucken da steht komplette Auflösung
der Rücklage da steht wir fordern einen
Tilgungsplan auch für die Schulden im
Rahmen der konjunkturkomponente dabei
sollten Privatisierungserlöse von über 2
Milliarden erzielt werden da war die
Forderung nach einem
Wirtschaftsförderungsprogramm leider
leider ist davon nichts mehr übrig
deshalb waren wir aufgefordert
Vorschläge zu machen wir haben das
gemacht wir haben einen Einsparungen
19 Milliarden ermittelt durch Abbau von
haushaltsresten Auflösung der Rücklage
Privatisierungserlöse und um
Förderprogrammen leider sind uns die
ampelfraktion da nicht gefolgt dabei
wäre noch ein Impuls einen Neustart
etwas was in Richtung
Wirtschaftsförderung geht in diesem Land
jetzt im Augenblick so wichtig um
bisschen mehr zukunftsgläubigkeit und
ein bisschen mehr Zutrauen in unserem
Land wieder zu erreichen und die
Verunsicherung und detailliert in diesem
Land zu nehmen
unsere Schwerpunkte waren Forschung und
Erprobung alternativen
Antriebstechnologien bei ihnen nichts
vorhanden weitere stillgelegte weiter
Nutzung stillgelegter als förderfelder
für Geothermie Unterstützung von
Handwerksbetrieben beim
energieträgerwechsel Aufbau von
rohstoff-offensive fürs antworten die
effizientere Gestaltung unserer Jugend
berufsagenturen Förderung von Mädchen
und Frauen in den Mund Berufsfeldern
Stärkung des girlsdays oder ein
inklusiven digitalpakt für berufliche
Bildung all das konnten sie
offensichtlich nicht mitgehen wir stehen
als CDU und CSU für die stärkeren der
äußeren und inneren Sicherheit wir
müssen den Bundeswehr Etat aufstocken
damit die laufenden Ausgaben nicht
weiter die in Position aus diesem Etat
verdrängt wir wollen die Aufstockung der
Notfallreserve beim Getreide wir
brauchen moderne Geräte und Ausrüstung
für Katastrophenschutz und Bundespolizei
wir wollen das THW stärker stärken wir
brauchen eine verbesserte
Notstromversorgung in unserem Land
genauso wie eine
trinkwassernotversorgung und wir
brauchen ein Investitionsprogramm für
den Starkregen all das haben sie leider
nicht mitgemacht wir waren für die
Anhebung der Pendlerpauschale und zwar
ab dem ersten Kilometer damit endlich
mal wieder Politik für den ländlichen
Raum gemacht wird die ist seit Übernahme
dieser Regierung nicht mehr da meine
Damen und Herren Deutschland kann doch
mehr wir müssen es nur wollen an dieser
Stelle
jetzt will ich auf ein zwei Punkte
eingehen erstmal Kollege Post
eins ist noch nicht richtig verstanden
unsere Hauptkritik ist der normale
Haushalt wird ganz normal weitergeführt
es werden die ampelprojekte durchgeführt
wie sie im Koalitionsvertrag beschrieben
wurden und alles was Krise ist das
bildet sich jetzt alles in
Sondervermögen ab und damit blendet man
Stück halt die Realität und
Wirtschaftlichkeit aus ich kann nicht
einfach sagen da nehme ich Milliarden
Schulden dafür aus ich muss beides
miteinander kombinieren und vernünftig
in die Zukunft zu gehen
der zweite Punkt wir müssen uns das
Thema haushaltsvorzukommen die
Investitionen werden höher dass es
richtig aber die Haushaltsreste steigen
noch viel schneller weil die Ministerien
das Geld nicht ausgeben man sieht doch
die vielen roten Karten die auch von
ihrer Fraktion von den ampelfraktionen
verteilt wurden wo gesagt wir wollen
berichtet wir sperren hier Mittel weil
wir gar nicht wissen wo die Regierung
das Geld für ausgibt und der Kindler das
war der Grund warum wir das beim WSF
nicht mitkommen können wir wissen bis
heute nicht wie die Bremsen gestaltet
sind wir wissen nicht wie die
Gewinnabschöpfung die neue Steuer wie
die ausgestaltet sind wir konnten ihnen
noch keinen Blankoscheck ausstellen
hierzu überhaupt wir werden nicht für
die Hilfen dass es unredlich danke schön
Christian Haase der haushaltspolitische
Sprecher der CDU CSU liegt die hier den
Finger in den Wunde aus Sicht zumindest
der Union und jetzt spricht Christian
Lindner der Bundesfinanzminister
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
wir beraten diesen Haushalt in Zeiten
größter wirtschaftlicher Unsicherheit
viele Familien sorgen sich darum wie sie
über die Runden kommen viele
mittelständische Betriebe die seit
vielen Generationen in Familienhand sind
sorgen sich um ihre eigene
wirtschaftliche Existenz und bei diesen
Haushaltsberatungen bei dieser Debatte
bei einzelnen Beiträgen am heutigen
Vormittag habe ich den Eindruck dass die
gesellschaftliche und ökonomische
Realität nicht bei jedem angekommen ist
Kollege Haase
Kollegah Haase die beste Form der
Wirtschaftsförderung und Sie haben ja
von Wirtschaftsförderung gesprochen die
beste Form der Wirtschaftsförderung ist
doch dass ein Betrieb angesichts der
steigenden Gaspreise überhaupt noch
produzieren kann und deshalb ist es
richtig dass die Koalition eine Strom
und eine gaspreisbremse auf den Weg
gebracht hat
hier habe ich im übrigen die habe ich im
übrigen auch keinen Widerspruch der
Opposition gehört von keinem von ihnen
wir stimmen ja auch offensichtlich darin
überein dass wir die Menschen und die
Wirtschaft mit den ruinösen Preisspitzen
nicht alleine lassen dürfen wir müssen
doch unsere wirtschaftliche Stärke
mobilisieren um unsere wirtschaftliche
Stärke auch für die Zukunft zu erhalten
deshalb ist es doch auch notwendig dass
wir in enormer Weise fiskalische Stärke
projizieren um einen Abwehrschirm
aufzustellen das haben sie nicht in
Frage gestellt und das ist auch richtig
dass sie es nicht in Frage stellen denn
wir müssen in diesen Zeiten dafür sorgen
dass das erhalten bleibt dass wir uns
über Jahrzehnte erarbeitet haben
offen sagt nur
offen bleibt nur und umstritten dann
zwischen den Koalitionen Regierung
einerseits und der Opposition
andererseits die Frage der Finanzierung
jetzt könnte man auf die Idee kommen wir
finanzieren das mit Steuererhöhungen der
Kollege Friedrich Merz hatte das ja ins
Gespräch gebracht im Zusammenhang mit
der Ertüchtigung der Bundeswehr ich
erinnere mich an diese Debatte der
Sachverständigenrat hat ist ebenfalls
angesprochen konnte übrigens aber auf
Nachfrage nicht ein Volumen oder ein
Mittel angeben sondern nur abstrakt
wurde das ins Gespräch gebracht ich
halte das für falsch angesichts der
großen Unsicherheit die wir haben
angesichts der privaten
investitionsbedarfe in saubere
Technologie angesichts der infrage
gestellten Wettbewerbsfähigkeit übrigens
auch durch den Inflation Redaktion Act
der Vereinigten Staaten wäre es ein
gefährliches
makroökonomisches Experiment in diesen
Zeiten auch noch die Steuern zu erhöhen
deshalb haben wir uns dagegen
entschieden
dagegen entschieden im Gegenteil die
Koalition hat bereitflächig Entlastungen
beschlossen dabei handelt sich um die
steuerliche Abzugsfähigkeit
beispielsweise der
Rentenversicherungsbeiträge die wir
verbessert haben Verbesserungen beim
häuslichen Arbeitszimmer Verbesserungen
beim Arbeitnehmer Pauschbetrag bereits
zu Beginn diesen Jahres
Sparer-Pauschbetrag ja und auch die
kalte Progression wird vollständig
ausgeglichen allein das sind
Mindereinnahmen von
18,6 Milliarden Euro im nächsten Jahr
wann soll es einen steuerlichen
Inflationsausgleich geben wenn ich in
Zeiten hoher Inflation und das macht die
Koalition
[Applaus]
wir werden auch über weitere steuerliche
Maßnahmen sprechen müssen mit Blick auf
den Haushalt
2024 wir müssen ja die Konjunktur
anschieben und da ist auch ein
sichtbarer steuerlicher Impuls notwendig
der Bundeskanzler hat bereits bei seiner
Regierungserklärung gesagt er spreche
sich für eine investitionsprämie bzw
super Abschreibung aus und damit wir aus
dieser Krise uns heraus investieren
können im privaten Bereich ist das eine
Maßnahme die 2024 rechtzeitig sein
könnte
der Haushaltsgesetzgeber wird noch
darüber sprechen der Bundesregierung
wird ihren Haushaltsentwurf 2024 im
nächsten Jahr ja erst vorlegen deshalb
spreche ich hier ja noch im Konjunktiv
Potenzial ist liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die Koalition hat einen
Bundeshaushalt aufgestellt der die
Schuldenbremse achtet übrigens ist die
flexibler als manche denken denn sie
erlaubt im Konjunkturverlauf auch höhere
Ausgaben innerhalb des Bundeshaushaltes
verfolgen wir unsere regulären
politischen Vorhaben die krisenbedingten
Mehrausgaben des abwehrschirms wir haben
wir im Wirtschaft und
Stabilisierungsfonds gebunden übrigens
auch deshalb weil wir nicht wissen wie
sie Strom und Gaspreise entwickeln
deshalb brauchen wir jetzt
Handlungsmöglichkeiten und auch
flexibilitäten um in diesen im nächsten
im übernächsten Jahr regieren zu können
die cdu/csu kritisiert dass wir die
regulären Vorhaben der Koalition unter
der Schuldenbremse und die Bewältigung
mit der Krisenfolgen dass wir die
voneinander separieren und diese Kritik
diese Kritik der stellen wir uns und
dafür gibt es ja auch Argumente die auf
ihrer Seite sind und dennoch bei der
Abwägung von pros und konz haben wir uns
am Ende für diesen Weg entschieden weil
es der sichtbarste Beleg dafür ist dass
wir zwar die haushaltspolitische
Normalität noch nicht erreicht haben das
ist aber der Anspruch dieser Koalition
ist schnellstmöglich zum Prinzip
zurückzukehren dass nur das verteilt
werden kann was zuvor erwirtschaftet
worden
der Bundesfinanzminister hier mit einer
prägnanten Rede Tenor auf jeden Fall ist
dieser Haushalt besser als wenn man die
Steuern erhöht mit ihm nicht Kai
Gottschalk jetzt für die afd-fraktion
erst der finanzpolitische Sprecher der
AFD
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
verehrte Kollegen über Steuerzahler da
draußen muss darauf eigenen Herr Kollege
Lindner es ist ja wohl das Minimum dass
die Regierung das versucht zu reparieren
was sie durch ihre gescheiterte
Energiepolitik verursacht haben aber sie
lindern es nur man könnte auch sagen sie
Lindner hier ein bisschen aber sie heben
den Schaden doch nicht auf das ist die
pflichtverdammt noch mal das zu tun
gegenüber den Unternehmern den
Steuerzahlern die Angst vor der nächsten
Stromrechnung haben meine Damen und
Herren
und eine Korrektur Herr Lindner das Jahr
2022 haben sie vergessen sie sagen die
kalte Progression gleichen sie aus nein
wenn nur in Teilen da könnten wir in die
Debatte gehen aber sie fangen erst zum
ersten Januar 2023 an meine Damen und
Herren dieses Jahr ist anscheinend
nichts teuer geworden auch das
verschweigen sie es ist eine Expos der
Entlastung meine Damen und Herren
sie Rühen sich also doch damit in diesem
Haushalt dass sie die Schuldenbremse
einhalten das mag nach ihren
juristischen kriegsereien für sie so
funktionieren auch wenn viele Experten
meine Damen und Herren das wirklich
anders sehen aber ich frage mich ehrlich
ob es in Zeiten von galoppierender
Inflation und einer sich anbahnenden
Rezession auch richtig und notwendig ist
diese juristischen Spielräume
auszunutzen meine Damen und Herren ich
würde eher sagen sie tricksen und
balancieren beim Haushalt wie es
Wirecard bei den Bilanzen getan hat und
das Ende war dabei das kennen wir hier
alle meine Damen und Herren im Parlament
aber vermutlich wollen Sie diese Debatte
auch nicht hören sie haben ja nicht ohne
Grund das Thema der bundesschulden und
der allgemeinen Finanzverwaltung ohne
Debatte für Freitag auf die Tagesordnung
gesetzt ich erinnere Sie daran dass Sie
diese im März noch bei den hier zu
beratenden Einzelplänen 08 und 20 unter
die Überschrift allgemeiner
finanzdebatte beraten haben vermutlich
eben wollen sie ihm nicht über die
Verdopplung der Kreditaufnahme und die
vom Bundesrechnungshof attestierten
verdeckten Schulden reden meine Damen
und das ist keine Transparenz das ist
schuldenkoalition live und so verbauen
sie die Zukunft der vielen jungen
Menschen die hier sehr auf den Tribünen
die Schulden von heute das in eure
Steuererhöhung und die Renten die
gekürzt werden von morgen meine Damen
und Herren
also ein Schelm wäre auch böses dabei
denkt und Liebe Steuerzahler wenn Sie
nun dachten dass diese Bundesregierung
mit einem von der FDP geführten
Finanzministerium in Zeiten wo eben so
viele Menschen Angst vor den nächsten
Rechnungen haben in der
Bereinigungssitzung des Haushalts als
schones genutzt hätte um den Rotstift
und Sparmaßnahmen durchzudrücken nein
auch da Fehlanzeige dieser
Bundesregierung meine Damen und Herren
betreibt Raubbau an ihrer Zukunft sie
stellt das größte Risiko für die Zukunft
da und nicht der herbei zitierte und
geredete angebliche Klimawandel meine
Damen und Herren
und machen Sie sich selbst ein Bild
schauen Sie in die Einzelpläne ich nehme
hier einfach mal den Einzelplan 08
Ausgaben von 9,7 Milliarden Euro damit
steigt dieser Plan in diesem Jahr
alleine um zehn Prozent meine Damen und
Herren hier geht wohl auch das Motto
Quantität statt Qualität und wenn ich
mir die bildungsabläufe einiger
Abgeordneter dieser schuldenkoalition
ankomme ist das auch kein Wunder ich
zitiere mit Erlaubnis der Präsidentin
deutsche Verwaltung explodiert
ampelregierung stammt 10.000 Stellen aus
dem Boden der Staat insgesamt also wir
beschäftigen 300.000 Personen
kostenpunkt 40 Milliarden Euro meine
Damen und Herren dieser ampelregierung
hält die Bürger in unserem Land zum
Sparen an gleichzeitig vernichtet aber
die Inflation und ihre Ausgaben Politik
die Zukunft dieses Landes sie hätten die
Zeichen der Zeit erkennen müssen Herr
Lindner und die gesamte Regierung der
Kanzler ist nicht da auch das ist wieder
klar und alle ideologische motivierten
und überflüssigen Posten streichen
sollen Personal wunderbar Effektivität
Effizienzsteigerung der Ministerien und
Behörden während einer Tagesordnung
gewesen diese Chance haben sie kläglich
verpasst der Steuerzahler der Zukunft
wird es zahlen müssen die Quittung meine
Damen und Herren werden sie hoffentlich
dieser schuldenkoalition schon bald bei
der Wahl hier in Berlin und hoffentlich
auch bei den nächsten Wahlen in den
Landtagen geben wir machen da nicht mit
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion dr
Thorsten Rudolf
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren
Weltmeister wird nur wer neben der
spielerischen Qualität auch über den
nötigen Zusammenhalt verfügt und ist die
Aufstellung des Bundeshaushalts 2023
kein Wettbewerb der nötige Zusammenhalt
aber spielte für uns eine entscheidende
Rolle und in dieser Woche zur
Verabschiedung des Haushalts können wir
selbstbewusst sagen diese Haushalt ist
gut für unser Land denn dieser Haushalt
sichert den Zusammenhalt in der
Zeitenwende
genau darum geht es meine Damen und
Herren um Zusammenhalt es gibt Kräfte
die das Potenzial haben uns auseinander
zu reißen dazu zählt natürlich der
völkerrechtswidrige Angriffskrieg
Russlands dazu zählt natürlich der
Klimawandel dazu zählen natürlich auch
all die unerwünschten Folgen von
corona-pandemie und Krieg hohe
Energiekosten unsichere Lieferketten
hohen Inflation Abnehmen des Wachstum
kleiner werdende finanzielle Spielräume
und soziale Härten alle diese Krisen
besitzen das Potenzial zu spalten die
internationale Gemeinschaft genauso wie
unsere Gesellschaft es gibt vermutlich
auch kaum jemanden der sich dieser
Gefahr nicht bewusst wäre
daran statt konstruktiv daran
mitzuarbeiten die Gefahren zu mindern
versuchen einige politisch Kapital aus
diesen Krisen zu schlagen indem sie
verschiedene gesellschaftliche Gruppen
gegeneinander ausspielen leider sitzen
einige davon auch in diesem Raum dass
meine Damen und Herren ist ein
gefährliches Spiel lassen Sie es mich
deshalb ganz klar sagen die
Ampelkoalition spielt dieses Spiel nicht
mit wir setzen auf Zusammenhalt
Zusammenhalt in der Zeitenwende das
heißt erstens wir sind solidarisch mit
denen die es nötig haben wir lassen es
nicht zu dass unser Land das unsere
Gesellschaft gespalten werden deshalb
hat diese Koalition drei
entlastungspakete von insgesamt 95
Milliarden Euro geschnürt deshalb hat
diese Koalition zusätzlich ein
Abwehrschirm von 200 Milliarden Euro
gespannt um mit der Strom und
gaspreisbremse die Belastungen durch die
hohen Energiekosten abzumindern um
Arbeitsplätze zu sichern und um die
Strukturen unserer Wirtschaft zu
erhalten deshalb entlastet diese
Koalition die Breite Mitte der
Einkommensbezieher mit dem
inflationsausgleichsgesetz spürbar und
deshalb unterstützt diese Koalition vor
allem auch mit dem Bürgergeld mit der
Erhöhung des Kindergelds auf 250 Euro
und mit dem neuen Wohngeld plus gerade
diejenigen die inmitten einer der
schwersten Krisen seit Bestehen der
Bundesrepublik dringend Hilfe nötig
haben
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Zusammenhalt in der Zeitenwende das
heißt zweitens wir stehen zu unserer
internationalen Verantwortung und wir
lassen die Menschen nicht im Stich wir
sind solidarisch mit unseren
europäischen und transatlantischen
Partnern und wir sind solidarisch mit
den Ländern des globalen Südens deshalb
haben wir eine Milliarde Euro für den
Kampf gegen den Hunger noch in diesem
Jahr freigegeben deshalb erhöhen wir für
das nächste Jahr die etas von außen und
Entwicklungshilfeministerium zusätzlich
um jeweils eine Milliarde Euro deshalb
stärken wir den weltweiten Kampf gegen
den Hunger deshalb stärken wir die
humanitäre Hilfe deshalb stärken wir die
zivile Krisenprävention aber deshalb
investieren wir auch in unsere
Sicherheit und Freiheit und erfüllen
unsere Bündnis Verpflichtungen deshalb
schließen wir jetzt schnell die
Fähigkeitslücken unserer Bundeswehr mit
der Rekordsumme von erneut über 50
Milliarden Euro im Verteidigungshaushalt
plus zusätzlich erstmals rund 8,4
Milliarden Euro aus dem 100 Milliarden
Euro Sondervermögen
meine Damen und Herren Zusammenhalt in
der Zeitenwende das heißt drittens wir
sind auch solidarisch mit unseren
Kindern und kinderskindern und stellen
die Weichen für eine gute Zukunft
deshalb investieren wir in die
Digitalisierung in Forschung und
Wissenschaft und in die Transformation
unserer Wirtschaft deshalb stellen wir
allein über den
klima-35 Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung
im nächsten Jahr deshalb investieren wir
massiv in die Gebäudesanierung in die
dekarbonisierung unserer Wirtschaft in
den Marktdurchbruch der
Wasserstoffwirtschaft in den Ausbau der
Lage Infrastruktur oder auch in die
Digitalisierung der Schiene
und Solidarität mit unseren Kindern
heißt auch das betone ich ausdrücklich
dass diese Ampelkoalition eine durch und
durch seriöse und verantwortungsvolle
Finanzpolitik Macht dazu gehört erstens
dass die krisenbedingten Mittel für die
Bundeswehr und die energiehilfen jeweils
gesondert ausgewiesen werden transparent
und mit klarer Zweckbestimmung und dazu
gehört auch dass diese Ampelkoalition im
Bundeshaushalt 2023 die Schuldenbremse
wieder einhält die Solidität dieser
Koalition beweisen dabei insbesondere
zwei der wichtigsten Kennziffern 1 wird
die Schuldenquote in den nächsten Jahren
trotz aller entlastungspakete und
abwehrschirme leicht sinken sinken meine
Damen und Herren mit anderen Worten
Deutschland und seiner öffentlichen
Finanzen werden nach der Krise in etwa
so da stehen wie vor der Krise wir
unterbrechen lediglich die schnelle
Entschuldigung der letzten Jahre
und deswegen ist es auch so
verwunderlich dass sie als Opposition
immer nur auf die absoluten Zahlen
eingehen und damit ökonomisch nicht mal
die halbe Wahrheit erzählen es ist
vielmehr klar Christian Lindner setzt
hier den verantwortungsvollen
finanzpolitischen Kurs von Olaf Scholz
fort und zweitens und sicherlich genauso
bemerkenswert in diesem Zusammenhang der
Bund plant trotz Schuldenbremse im
nächsten Jahr mit rekordinvestitionen
von 71 Milliarden Euro 71 Milliarden
Euro das ist eine weltmeisterliche
Investitionsquote meine Damen und Herren
die für 2023 geplante Neuverschuldung
wird gerade nicht verfrühstückt sondern
komplett und vollständig in die Zukunft
unseres Landes investiert damit unsere
Kinder es besser haben liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen kurz und
gut Deutschland spielt im kommenden Jahr
mit einer starken Abwehr gegen die
großen Krisen mit einem mindestens
genauso starken Angriff um die Zukunft
zu gewinnen und um unser Land und die
Welt sicherer gerechter und
klimafreundlicher zu machen und weil wir
dabei auf mannschaftliche
Geschlossenheit setzen und weil wir auf
Zusammenhalt in der zeitenwände sitzen
wird unser Land ganz vorne mitspielen
davon bin ich überzeugt herzlichen Dank
der Bundestag debattiert über Finanzen
und Bundesrechnungshof über den
Gesamthaushalt quasi in der zweiten und
dann dritten Lesung jetzt als nächste
Rednerin Janine Wissler eine die
Fraktionschefin Ballon der Linksfraktion
Dietmar Bartsch ist der andere Fraktion
ale Spaltung sogar ihr
Sachverständigenrat empfiehlt in dieser
Situation zumindest zeitweise die
Steuern für Spitzenverdiener und
Vermögende zu erhöhen und ich sage ihnen
wenn sie schon nicht als auf uns als
Linke gehören ja dann hören Sie doch
wenigstens auf die Sachverständigen die
sie selber benannt haben und erhöhen Sie
in dieser Situation die Steuern für die
Reichen in diesem Land für Menschen mit
kleinem Einkommen die von Armut
betroffen sind tun sie viel zu wenig in
diesem Haushalt die Kinder
Grundsicherung die verschieben die
schieben Sie auf die lange Bank aber bei
der aktienrente da ging es deutlich
schneller und beim Bürgergeld erleben
wir ein unwürdiges Schmierentheater auf
dem Rücken der Beschäftigte der
Betroffenen erst legt die Ampel ein mehr
als dürftigen Gesetzentwurf vor der mit
der Überwindung von Hartz IV wirklich
überhaupt nichts zu tun hat 53 Euro mehr
hat doch nichts mit Respekt zu tun die
sie den Menschen versprochen haben meine
Damen und Herren und diese Mick viel
Verbesserungen bei Schonvermögen bei
zwangsumzügen und Sanktionen von denen
die Menschen die so wie jetzt schon im
Hartz iv-bezug sind sowieso nichts haben
das muss man ja immer wieder sagen diese
mickrigen Verbesserungen werden aller
Voraussicht nach dem
Vermittlungsausschuss nicht mal
überleben dank der Union mit
freundlicher Unterstützung der FDP und
das ist wirklich beschämend was sie dort
getan haben meine Damen und Herren weil
die Union den Menschen nicht mal die
kleinste Verbesserung gönnt und versucht
Niedriglöhner gegen
sozialleistungsbezieher auszuspielen das
ist chemik als ob hart arbeitende
Menschen von denen sie immer reden
irgendeine Verbesserung davon hätten
wenn die alleinerziehende Hartz
iv-bezieherinnen zwar sanktioniert wird
weil sie den Termin verpasst hat oder
zwangsumziehen muss nein was diese
Menschen brauchen das sind wirksame
tarifreie Gesetze und höhere
Mindestlöhne und da war die CDU immer
dagegen er hat immer dagegen gestimmt
also deswegen ist es heuchlerisch dass
sie sich als Anwalt der hart arbeitenden
Menschen darstellen Frau Präsident ich
komme zum Schluss das ist ein Wettbewerb
der Schäbigkeit auf dem Rücken der
Betroffenen den wir uns nicht beteiligen
während wir ihnen wären bei Ihnen die
Superreichen diesem Land da sind ihnen
selbst schon Vermögen in Milliardenhöhe
nicht hoch genug also von daher da
sollte man ansetzen bei den
Schonvermögen der Superreichen aber doch
nicht bei den Altersrücklagen von
Menschen im sozialleistungsbezug vielen
Dank
Janine Wissler ist natürlich die
Parteivorsitzende der Linken Person
meine Damen und Herren da war ich glaube
ich ein wenig abgelehnt aber die von der
Kollegen haben es ja richtig
eingeblendet apropos eingeblendet sie
sehen es schon links im kleinen Bild wir
erwarten hier gleich Stellungnahmen
zunächst der Fraktionen der Ampel zu der
Einigung beim Bürgergeld ist
offensichtlich gegeben hat in den
Vorverhandlungen denn der
Vermittlungsausschuss zwischen Bundestag
und Bundesrat sitzt der erst morgen doch
zurück zum Haushalt mit Sebastian
Schäfer und in Wildungen unser Land
steckt in der wahrscheinlich
schwierigsten Situation seitdem seit
Demokrat wir starten 1949 begründet
wurde die Multidimensionalität so meine
Damen und Herren und so schnell geht es
manchmal jetzt meine Damen und Herren so
schnell geht es manchmal jetzt springen
wir zurück auf die Fraktionsebene über
uns dort jetzt also Katja Mast schon zu
sehen Britta Hasselmann und Johannes
Vogel die Parlamentarischen
Geschäftsführer der Ampel